[musique]
Marie Sylvia Manuel dans s'était du déjà vu
on avait parlé un Petit peu de quelque chose
J'ai choisi mais voilà, je voulais continuer
cette Conversation parce qu'j'étais
frustré Il y AV Plein de choses ne marche pas
avait Pas EU Le temps de parler d'abord
Il faut redire un mot quand même du du
Festival de monfort laamorie parce que
Plus ça VA et Plus ça Se approche de la 3e
édition du Festival théâtre et
vendredi 11 samedi 12
dimanche 13 mai Don vous êtes La
directrice artistique et alors auquel
Festival auquel a participé évidemment DES
professionnels Il y a de la musique a Il
a tout un mélange de choses de la fois
d'artistes professionnels d'artistes de
qualité amateur de musique de spectacle
Pour enfant Il y a des mimes Il y a une
troupe d'improvisation enfin Il y a
j'espère un joli programme éclectique
Sur 3 jours commenter sur fait Il faut sur
Se Dit Il faut tout inventer quand On
Est à La tête deun Festival Comme
celui-là C'est très excitant C'est très
excitant parce qu'on a une mission La
mission C'est de remplir Les cases Si Je
puis Dire en allant trouver DES
lunettes un Petit peu partout en
allant Les voir Pour voir Si tout VA
Bien donc C'est très C'est on fait une
sorte de marché mais un marché très
agréable à faire alors j'étais un peu
frusré Sur Sur AU fond parce que ça ça
ça passionne toujours Sur votre enfance
j'avais dit vous vous êtes la la la
fille de Robert manuel et de claudine
coer donc vous avez trempé Dans Le
théâtre Si Je puis Dire vous êtes N
dedans quoi mais Je vais vous dire sur un
parce que j'ai un frère aussi tellement
qui s'appelle évidemment jean-baptiste
Il pouvati Pas s'appeler marcel même Si
Papa a beaucoup aimé Marcel Achard
spécialiste spécialiste de tout à fait
et nous parce que justement on voyait
nos parents ont DES soucis d'être Dans
Le Rouge à La banque et cetera et cetera
il voulait Pas faire ça du tout parce
que c'était une vie difficile malgré Le
Le comédien extrêmement connu votre mère
aussi sur une enfance extraordinaire sur
alors On Est On Est parisien On Est né à
Paris et on habitait neilli et Je Je
Me souviens d'une EU une enfance mais
princière mais princière nous étions DES
petits princes sur une UE sur était
extrêmement heureux une EX maison
magnifique DES chiens toute La famille
était avec nous Les grand-mères Les
arrières-grands-mères enfin c'était
J'ai un Souvenir d'enfance fantastique
merveilleux et et Vos parents étaient en là
La journée comment ça Se passe ça Je
m'en souviens Pas très Bien Je crois
qu'il é Je Les vois ils NE sont Pas
absent sauf Le
Soir Soir parce qu' Ma grand-mère était
avec nous qui nous a élevé Ma grand-mère
puisque Les parents travaillaient donc
C'est une enfance à la fois avec les parents
et sans parents Si vous voulez mais très
très très agréable et puis on avait
C'est ça qui Est fantastique aussi Dans
l'éducation C'est qu'on avait autour de
nous DES statuts puisque Papa faisait
La Collection de lunettes N
seulement de molière mais de tout CE qui
Est spectacle et musicau et tout ça et
il avait DES disques il avait DES livres
imaginez qu'au Point de vue éducation
donc vous avez lu tout Le temps quoi
parce que c'était là parce que c'était
là et donc on avait tout mot passant on
avait tout guitare c'était merveilleux
C'est Pour ça que Je trouve que Dans
l'éducation Si on entoure Le Les Les
jeunes gens enfin Les petits enfants de
tout ça et qui peuvent piocher ils Se
Font leur éducation et C'est merveilleux
Pour l'écriture Pour La lecture après
jeanp raconte ça Dans Les
motsblement C'est vrai était Dans une
bibliothèque vous aussi c'était donc
pareil mais vous dites voilà parce que
on pourrait s'imaginer Je Dire acteur un
comédien aujourd'hui euh DES comédiens
d'ailleurs Comme Comme Robert manuel C
aujourd'hui serait très riche euh Non
mais C'est vrai là vous dites F c'était
c'était Pas on était très heureux voilà
mais mais c'était Pas forcément voilà
vous croiez Pas Sur l'argent bah écoutez
on avait une vie Si c'était sur Aura EU
DES montagnes mais C'est ça mais Papa Il
était Comme ça c'était un Prince né voil
c'était un Prince et je peux vous dire
que Tous ceux qui qui s'en
souviennent et qui l'ont connu Se
souviennet DES dîners à La maison DES
31 décembre à La maison où Pour Les
amis Comme une sorte De Prince oriental
Il offre DES jambons de bayonne Comme
ça Tous Les hommes DES gros saucissons
AUX dames DES bouquins mais c'était de
la folie mais c'était merveilleux
c'était complètement fou et c'était qui
Les amis c'était Le tout Paris de Pierre
M jusquà Michel rou même Paul meuris Je
Je me souviens de Paul Meuris à La maison
et Comme on était trop Petit qu'on
devait aller à l'école moi jeis Pas Si G
peut-être vu Le monocle oui
effectivement parce que voilà c'était
avec un visage oui et Papa a tourné avec
Simon signor donc Je me souviens de ces
dîner là tout Le monde était à La maison
parce que Papa savait recevoir et vous
étiez admis Dans C dîner ou alors Les
enfants Bon on disait Bonjour Bonjour
Monsieur Bonjour Madame on était en
pyjama Je me souviens très très Bien et
puis quand même Je Je me souviens aussi
Comme je voulais Pas aller à l'école
parce que je savais qu'il y avait
quelque chose de Formidable qui Se
passer à la maison on avait une immense
table avec rempli de convive j'étais
en dessous de la table Ah Je pouis Pas
m'empêcher Ah oui Comme jeun vivent
taabou Sur S La table de la sdn
exactement attendez-vous à savoir ça
donc C'est une enf Formidable ça C'est
et puis après vous partez Dans Les
Evelin àprs Les ivelines à plaisir Dans
une maison de 600 M Car à plaisir rz
compte là hein he bah Il y a EU DES
travaux alors là Je peux vous Dire C'est
très l'apparence était extrêmement
Rupine nous étions très Rupin
d'apparence et mais Papa était une était
un fou mais merveilleux quoi c'était un
panier percé Comme on Dit ou on peut
Dire ça vous savez pourquoi parce que Il
était Pas complètement dépensier mais
vous lui présentez Je NE sais Pas moi
une chaussette en forme de molière Il
vous l'achetait Ah oui Il y avait sur lui
on lui présentait DES croûtes molières
Il l'achetait Il Les achetait Je me
souviens-toi d'un d'un tableau en bouton et
tissu que Pas Il l'a acheté Ah oui parce
que c'était molière parce que c'était
Molière qu'est-ce qu'elle Est devenu La
Collection et Ben ELLE a été vendue par
deux ou trois fois Je crois Bien
Il y en avait Si Je PE tellement Dire Il
y avait plusieurs canapés en quelque chose
sorte donc Les impôts sont passés par
ici ils NE reviendront Plus par là
j'espère parce que C'est C'est fini mais
donc la Collection a dû Comme ça ELLE a
été utile Pour payer Les dettes et puis
alors ton frère lui Il Est resté voilà
Dans Le théâtre Non alors jean-baptiste
Il Est professeur de lettre Il Est
professeur de L Il a fait qui Est Pas
loin de votre père aussi puis que AU
fond voilà c'était c'était aussi un
excellentum Ah remarquable remarquable
et ce qui était tout à fait incroyable
parce que J'ai assisté à ces cours à
Papa Il était Rude nous sommes d'accord
ferme avec de la discipline de
professeur mais tout pter vers l'élève
Pour que l'élève lui montre un peu
l'envie qu'il avait parce que Si l'élève
était là C'est qu'il voulait faire Le
métier Il y avait une Passion sin C'est
n'est Pas La peine d'être là et donc Il
était Comme Dit CE Grand philosophe
belge conscient n'est-ce Pas asse assz Tous
ces là élèves Pour en tirer Le meilleur
deux mêmes et Tous Les élèves Il en a EU
énormément d'élèves Papa vous parleront
toujours avec tendresse de Papa et CE
qu'il faisait voir-vous C'est que Le
matin donc Les cours étaent 8h30 Je
crois 8h 8h30 Il arrive toujours avec
DES croissants et Tous Les élèves à
Daniel Cololla enfin Tous Tous Tous Les
collègues francis perin enfin Le Le sav
s'en souviennet Il avait DES DES
croissants avec lui alors évidemment Il
dis très beau quoi ça pouvait être
paternaliste mais c'était Pas ça C'est
parce qu'il savait qu'il y avait DES
élèves qui Avent Pas qui avaiit Pas
assez de S Pour manger ou même qui Pour
payer Les cours faisiant un Double
travail et donc voilà Il y avait ça
aussi et vous vous même Il vous a donné
DES coups ou parce que vousz travé avec lui
mais est-ce que vous êtes Comme Les
enfants Les J'ai appris Mon métier en
étant Sur Son assistante et une
assistant à La à La mise en scène C'est
un Petit peu Si Je puis Dire Le Le Le Le
caporal par rapport AU AU commandant
voyez-vous AU capitaine donc J'ai appris
par être comédienne en remplaçant Les
acteurs qui n'étaient Pas là Ah d'accord
parce qu'une répétition doit Bien Se
passer du début jusqu'à La Fin oui donc
Si quelqu'un Est Pas là Il faut Il faut
Le remplacer sans gêner Les autres
les acteurs donc faut être juste et tout ça
donc J'ai beaucoup remplacé DES acteurs
qui avaient plein de choses à faire puis
voilà C'est C'est venu AU Sur Le terrain
Je suis tout ça Sur Le terrain alors on
parlait de ton frère donc qui qui qui
fait autre chose qui Est enseignant vous
ont DES demi-sœurs aussi qui ell alors
Son Rem DES grandes actrices de Thoi Il
y a Catherine Salvia ou qui Est La
doyenne de la comédie française qui continue
la la ligé à la comédie française voilà
et christine mot qui Est aussi une
actrice absolument merveilleusenelle oui
oui et ça C'est quand même
extraordinaire ça DES DES Non mais DES
lignées de C'est joli moi Je trouve ça
très joli est-ce qu'il y a DES DES DES
DES petits enfants qui arrivent qui qui
serait Dans la mais on a Ah écoutez J'ai
mes neveux donc Les fils de mes frères
de Mon frère euh qui sont doués Pour Les
lettres Pour alors nous verrons Bien
nous verrons Bien vous aimeriez Je veux
rien du tout vo Je Je préfère Dire
écoute qu'est-ce que tu as envie Tu veux
faire ça bah vas-y carrément mais avec
Passion et Talent Si sinon que CE soit
par goût et que ça NE Les quitte jamais
de leur vie quoi CE goût Pour Les
lettres Pour Le théâtre Pour la poésie
alors évidemment donc on parlait de C
ces soirées chez vous avec voilà t t
Tous Les grands acteurs toutes Les
grandes actrices qui sont et comédiens
et comédiennes qui sont Vénus chez vous
euh Il y a une EU aussi alors Il y a une EU la
télévision qui était importante euh avec
on reprend un Petit peu il aujourd'hui
après l'avoir abandonné c'était c'était
Pierre Sabac qui faisait ça ça s'it AU
théâtre CE Soir c'était merveilleux
c'était merveille vrai qu'on y a
beaucoup vu Robert manuel Dans C'est
vrai Je crois qu'il A fait Plus de 300
mises en scène C C'est et on reconnaissance
SA patte Son humour Son parce qu'il
Adore Les auteurs Comme Louis Verneuil
Bien sûr C'est On reconnaî SA patte et
Son Style et puis La troupe d'acteur
Alain Fedo remarquable
acteur absolument absolument du Grand
George et c'était merveilleux Le et très
difficile technique Pour Les acteurs
parce qu'il y avait 24 répétitions et
après 24 répétitions une capture en
Direct en Direct en Direct il c'était en
Direct donc il fallait Pas Se touper Comme
vous dites et alors que maintenant on
reprend Le principe mais sur VA Dans
DES DES théâtres où Les pièces sont déjà
jouées C'est ça C'est DES pièces qui ont
déjà été joué vo voilà qui une sorte de
R mux fait Pour La télévision hein
c'était vraiment fait Pour La télévision
alors il y avait deux noms qui sont
restés DES noms mythiques C'est Donald
cardwell et Roger et Roger Art décor de
Costume Roger de Donald Card et Ben
écoute les professeurs oui l'un et l'autre R Pour
tout Le monde C'est DES NS mais Il y a
Pas de visage on sait mê Pas sils ont
existé Si ils ont existé ils ont existé
Je Les Ai rencontre bah Roger et c'était
deux esthètes voyez-vous deux artistes
vraiment et Roger Je l'appelais Roger
bah oui J'ai connu tout Petit Roger
c'était un un esthète un Grand monsieur
artiste qui dessinait extrêmement bien
qui fumait beaucoup d'ailleurs et qui
faisait DES désins incroyables DES
maquettes et qui était un artiste
extrêmement habile et Donald Cardwell
J'ai beaucoup travaillé avec lui même
après Le théâtre CE Soir parce que Il
m'a fait l'honneur d'être Le costumier
DES spectacle que J'ai monté donc vous
vous Rendez compte et alors par exemple
un jeu comment voir-vous physiquement
Donald Cardwell commente vous vous
l'imaginez Ah Je te vois assez Grand
ouais euh assez Grand assez mince voilà
un peu dandi Je NE sais Pas alors Il
était Pas Grand Il était Petit parce
qu'il était à l'origine un danseur Ah
d'accord avec un danseur un Noir américain
danseur Noir américain était Comme ça
vous savez Il parlait Comme ça Salut
patrice VA Bien Il était Noir américain
jamais Il était Noir et d'ailleurs Dans
Le un DVD de Le Noir te V Si Bien
mythique avec Jean lepoulin Maria Pacome
à La La Fin Il y a un Petit diablotin
Noir c'estii Ah Ben voilà sur précipité
làdessus lui merci infiniment Al Je
rappelle Je rappelle quand même Le titre
de votre dernier livre AUX éditions DES
quatre saisons ça
s'appelle N d'autres Tomb d'autres
Tomb texte on en avait parlé texte à
Dire et à lire merci merci infiniment
merci à vous merci infinim et puis à
très vite avec plaisir et n'oublions pas
Le Festival trois et patrimoine 11 12 et
13 Ma qu'on Se Le dise merci
[musique]
beaucoup